if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which
[Music]
[Music]
all right i'm gonna interrupt because we
it's just too busy today there's too
much going on and uh
people are clearly sick of that song
anyway we are hoping
hoping hoping for some interesting new
material but i'm gonna jump in because i
have so many things to talk about i did
see people in the chat i don't know if
it's a joke or not but
people asking if i've announced my next
vaccation as some of you know
i was in aruba the dutch caribbean last
week fully vaccinated and wearing a mask
and a beekeeper's outfit
uh with a hazmat suit on top of that and
a suit of armor on top of that
um and you know some interestingly
enough some friends want to go to
iceland
because iceland is open to vaccinated
people
but i was on the iceland uh travel
website yesterday
i start to feel like maybe i'm having a
cognitive issue
i can't actually figure out what's going
on in iceland like
if you're vaccinated you can go but you
still have to take
a test when you arrive and you don't get
the results for 24 to 48 hours
and you're supposed to quarantine while
waiting results but
if you're vaccinated does that apply and
then i was checking out like the travel
to iceland subreddit where everybody's
saying everything's closed right now
because iceland's on lockdown so like
why would i
i just don't understand what's going on
like i know that iceland keeps coming up
on a list of vaccinated people can go to
iceland
but i don't understand like okay but you
can go but then be in a hotel and is
anything open
and i i don't know i don't know it was
who knows but in any case nothing
nothing planned as of right now
we are standing by for joseph r biden jr
announcing executive action on gun
safety
i support this in principle now i have
to see what he's going to announce
but if you go back to after sandy hook
obama had the white house democrats had
the house
democrats had the senate 90 percent
american support for universal
background checks
and republicans in the gun lobby were
able to stop it
so i if you couldn't get something as
popular as background checks done then
what are we waiting for i don't know how
else you get anything done
on guns so i like the fact that joe
biden is doing something and he's doing
it just
um three and a two and a half months
into his presidency
let's see what he announces let's see
what he announces and that will be
uh momentarily a big big news
as some of you know pacman graffiti
has started showing up around the
country
and here is another one that was pointed
out to me
this one is in man oh this
this is the oakland one this is the
oakland one that i showed you guys not
long ago and people came to me via email
and they said sir
there's pacman graffiti i've been sent
another one this one's kind of far off
let's see if i can zoom it here is
another this looks like a one of those
concrete barriers on the side of the
highway as you can see there
oh hold on a second where is it oh now i
don't even know there it is
really really strong stuff okay so the
pacman graffiti
starting to be noticed around the
now the thing is i think that pacman
spelled the way i spell my name
is a common nickname in some i don't
remember if it's like
in filipino culture or like what if you
look on instagram and search my last
name there's a bunch of people from some
country that seem to use
pacman spelled like my last name as a as
a nickname
so i don't actually think any of these
necessarily have to do with me but these
are pretty strong when the team came to
me and said sir there's graffiti with
your name everywhere i
said show it to me show it to me so
that's it
caught up as far as graffiti goes
um mike says iceland has like five
people in it why would it be on lockdown
no i understand uh hold on travel to
iceland
travel to iceland subreddit
this is what i saw visiting iceland
sorry it's the visiting iceland
subreddit let me see if i can pull this
up
uh let me see here i was looking at this
yesterday
um linens no i don't have any questions
about linens
see it's stuff like this that's making
me doubt like okay test results from
keflavik airport
for those of you have gone how long did
it take to get test results usually
takes less than 24 hours
then someone says i think it'll take a
few days oh until someone who's
vaccinated right we just don't know yet
yeah
see iceland is on lockdown
if you're tested in the morning you
probably have it same day afternoon
you'll have it next day it's all
probabilities
24 hours yeah i just don't i just don't
know i'm just not sure
so the point is i have nothing to
announce i have nothing to announce
a correction republicans had the house
but democrats had the senate in 2012 to
2013. oh i stand corrected
i stand corrected let me thank some
early subscribers via twitch i want to
say thank you to
dan's news for the sub real lion for the
sub
o d w d i n c has subscribed for six
months
and uh that's three very much appreciate
that of course we welcome all
subscriptions twitch subscriptions
website memberships with the secret
unpublished coupon code
immoral 21. i have no unban requests to
adjudicate today
we did ban someone for spanish
anti-semitism the other day
um let's see they came in and said
oh and we bet so recent i guess i don't
have any unban requests but let me tell
you what the recent bans were for one
person got banned on the
tuesday stream uh by citing
um covid denialism
another person got banned on tuesday for
spanish and anti-semitism thinking it
was going to slip by
calling me a shitty jew and saying i
deserve colon cancer
and then who else was banned recently
another user was banned for saying oh a
bunch of weird stuff about biden
with someone needs to get him which
seemed over the line to me
so they were also banned but no on ban
requests so far
we actually we have a really high uh
success rate on bands like the bands are
mostly not overturned because they're
good bands
thanks to daring alkaline sumi long
and tamp for the twitch subs numbers
four
five and six very much appreciate that
also thanks to
randy mp for subscribing via twitch
and lastly um a very special thank you
to our newest website member at
joinpakman.com
matthew montgomery matthew montgomery
signing up using the coupon code
immoral 21. before we move on by the way
we had unfortunately the
wrath of the borderline illegal
discounts
led to a really aggressive police
interrogation listen to this this is sad
check this out hold on where is it david
um i was hoping that you would be
willing to write me a check because i
was at work
it was about one in the afternoon i got
arrested uh you know
sent to the uh county jail they
interrogated me for seven hours
about your um your discounts because
they're uh you're borderline criminal
and i
i lost the day's wages half a day's
wages because of it so i was hoping you
would write me a check for that
to ameliorate that thanks i'm willing to
ameliorate that yeah no if you lost a
day's wages because of an investigation
into my criminal discounts i'm totally
willing to
pay you back for that so just get in
touch one more voicemail to play
from mommyguy oh hold on let me do a few
other super chats
i voted blue last november i support
background checks but i also like my
guns gun rights are a huge issue for me
my support of democrats is contingent on
sensible gun control
yeah i i mean you know i know a lot of
gun owners on the left and
they all support universal background
checks we have a second amendment joe
biden's not canceling the second
amendment today everybody relax
would you join kip boga for a dynamic
duo of scam baiting
absolutely absolutely i'm a big fan of
kit boga kit boga has expressed being a
fan of the david pakman show it is a
mutual fandom
and i would love to do something with
kit boga
here is a voicemail from mommyguy but
it's his his reception is so bad we can
barely hear it check this out
hi so they wanted to start with
hi pumpkin but it's all chopped up
because their service is such trash
this is it's your money
so i heard it's your mommy they're get
they got their key line in but then it
just goes downhill
down the closet well i thought you'd be
drawing better because
that filthy behavior again young man and
you know what happens when
i catch you doing that let them lay
across
mommy's lap naked and you get a good
old-fashioned country whipping from your
skit mommy
how old do you think this person is like
this sounds like a 50 year old guy
that's what's crazy what's going on in
this person's life
you never do that again
oh now they're applying for a job i
guess green
i cards you would now keep it over here
sit on mommy's lap and give her a nice
big wet kiss dude so anyway next time
try it with better reception because
that's just
pathetic i don't even know what what
you're doing i want to say thanks to
mommy chickson as well as hitachi
for signing up via twitch you are new
subscribers
9 and 10. we will open phone lines if we
get to 100
and of course as always uh the website
is wide open at joinpakman.com for sign
ups i will sing your praises when you
sign up on my website even if they are
overblown and hyperbolic
i would still i will still sing your pl
sing your praises
uh stop playing voicemails no need okay
home dog says you should get a gun the
same way you have to get a car right
there should be at least as much
licensing and insurance required for
guns as there is for
for cars james says the coupon code
should come with handcuffs because it's
a
steal yes i've been wondering do you
have youtube
analytics on the change of your
viewership demographics it seems more
international than us now on the david
pakman show
um yeah i don't know
let me see here let's take a look
oh you know what i actually there's a
reason i can't pull that out right now
yeah i'll check into that robert says do
democrats realize increasing numbers of
their voters own guns do we only want
al qaeda crowd to have guns yeah that's
why a lot of my friends have obtained
firearms in the last year they don't
want it to be only
al qaeda with uh with the guns that's
absolutely right
we are still in the middle of a video
contest where
we are accepting remixes of this video
and there are 10 memberships available
for people who remix this video
in a way that is relevant to the david
pakman show
so i have one new submission that came
in here is the newest submission
there are still free memberships
available okay so get yours in
because we are giving out 10. check us
out
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so that's not bad that's actually pretty
good i i don't think that that's a bad
one
um and again we only have six so far so
there's still memberships available
still memberships available all right
i want to say thank you to web shooter
for signing up via twitch you were new
member number 11.
i also want to say thank you to crystal
sixberry for signing up on my website
crystal is new member number 12 today at
joinpacman.com
and also thanks thank you to ler don
lerdon
signed up via twitch and his new member
number 13.
home dog says in japan you have to go
through multiple mental examinations in
order to get a weapon and score a 95 at
the gun range
america should try this out yeah if
there was a psych screening
for getting a firearm in the u.s i
believe let me let me think about this
i think probably 35
of american gun owners would not pass a
psych screening
does that number seem right to you guys
35 i think would be rejected for gun
ownership if there was a psych screening
more some people say it's more than 35
maybe 40
35 40 something like that okay
uh midge says since you won't respond to
my emails i want to see if you'd go on a
date with me there's a new thai
restaurant in town i'd love to try i'm
going to pass midge i appreciate it but
that's going to be a no for me
that's a no for me dog if you know what
i'm saying
uh people asking for the source video on
bongos if you go to um
youtube and you search for trump biden
bongos
it's the first thing that comes up so if
you're looking for the source
it's the first one
[Laughter]
all right so there is that uh we are
standing by
for joe biden and uh
that's the bongo meme if you're looking
for the source material
yeah people have been asking me to do a
hot tub
stream i don't even know what that means
don't you have to be careful with
electricity around hot tubs that seems
like it could be
possibly dangerous i don't know
oh there's a bernie bongos that sounds
funny actually hold on
bernie bongos
um is it this
that's actually pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
i like that let's see what else comes up
under bernie bongo's
[Music]
represent the people okay all right
we're gonna get off of that one that
one's less my
thing but that's interesting david i'd
say at least more than 50
of gun owners would fail a psychic
evaluation you know a psychic evaluation
they may pass psychiatric though would
be different
brad says 74.2 million americans would
fail the psych test
fair courtney says i appreciate your
interview with a republican lawyer it
may seem like a waste of time but we
need to know how to communicate with
people like them
i don't know that i really learned that
we really learned anything about how to
communicate
unfortunately uh i wish that we had but
dq says just got my second freizer dose
so happy to see how the
great the us is doing with vaccination
keep we have to keep
vaccinating keep it going keep
vaccinating
i want to say thank you to dr whofan
for signing up via twitch your new
member number 14.
have you saw the tucker carlson news bit
on canadian covid
camps it's a load of lies and funny pics
of jt
i haven't seen that i haven't seen that
i'm gonna check that out
have you guys seen by oh you know what i
do have
they're still going with the gutfeld
show they're still doing
the the same bit from all week check
this out vacation isn't the goal
conflict is and once you see this
framework it shows up
everywhere i mean take a look at what's
on cnn right now
so this is a comedy show on fox here's
another one check out how cringy this is
voter id law was racist meanwhile
they still have the masters right yeah
it's called the masters
if master bedrooms are racist the
masters are racist
masturbation is racist master shep
is racist what like what's the problem
here
is it that the writing's bad is it that
greg gutfeld
his prompter reads are terrible is it
that the live audience
sounds like i guess the answer is yes
to all of these questions what is
masturbation no i don't know is your dad
watching oh
your dad's in the audience very good joe
okay here's another one sensitive
subject
maybe that's why people often just see
what they want to see
right gensaki jen
i'm gonna show you some images and just
tell me what comes to mind
okay um i would say that is um
definitely
not a photo of kids
in uh cages and uh
what about this one oh that's that's
very interesting question
and i would just say um that is not
um two kids in two cages
and this wow a
butterfly
some people might see a um dolphin
but i definitely do see a butterfly
um and unfortunately that's also all the
time for
questions that's right-wing comedy guys
that's
comedy in case you guys didn't uh didn't
know
i want to say thank you to david hoyt
david hoyt just did something incredible
david hoyt just went to joinpackman.com
got a membership with the coupon code
immoral21
thank you david i very much appreciate
that and you are new member number 15
today
uh exciting stuff and i encourage you
to grab such a membership why do
right-wingers struggle with sarcasm and
humor
that's my question yeah i don't know i
don't know
have you watched cue into the storm on
hbo i actually don't have hbo
i have so much stuff that i watch
already i've never found a need to get
hbo i am watching season three of
stiesel it is arguably it's a top five
show on tv right now maybe top three
on netflix season three is out
tremendous
tremendous program have you heard any
updates on the status of the dream act
in the senate i have not
have you noticed how thousands of trump
supporters dislike white house videos
before they start yeah
like look at this one it has one it has
1700 dislikes already
this is this is the resistance against
biden disliking
biden events before they start have at
it guys
have at it doesn't bother me um
funny they are doing a spoof on
rorschach test when gutfeld's comedy is
the equivalent of a verbal ink plot
nicely done doc nicely done
chris's cool says will the
infrastructure bill rise above or below
2 trillion glad amtrak is getting an
overall boost but upset there's no high
speed rail
yeah you know when i saw the amtrak
proposal it's it's great that amtrak is
getting a boost
but it's like when you look at the map
of what amtrak could look like in 2035
it's really depressing it's really
depressing
like that's maybe in 2035 it'll look
that way it's pathetic
i'm on the left but i fear further gun
control what do you mean further there's
not nothing's been done
further i fear further gun control will
lead to more violent crime and seeing as
most violent crime is committed with
black market guns it will only
strengthen that market and hurt
responsible gun owners
yeah let's see what joe biden proposes
first okay
david i've got a question that's been
bugging me if the rights stand so firmly
by the second amendment why do they keep
ignoring the whole well-regulated
militia part
so the reason i don't tend to get into
that is the
the definition of regulated in the
second amendment
is arguably not regulation in the way
that
we colloquially use it today so that's
why i tend to not
do like a linguistic analysis
satirizing disadvantaged people requires
empathy
you know one of the things i i'm going
to
mention on today's a podcast about
why the um gutfeld
show is not funny is that the
type of comedy they are doing is like
the adult
version of the high school kids who make
fun of the one
disabled kid where it's like this is the
wrong comedy it's not clever
it's not innovative i i think that
there may be something there sort of in
that analogy
and uh we're going to talk about that on
the broadcast show today
thanks to matt b matt b just
did an incredible humanitarian act matt
b just signed up at jointpakman.com
and his new member number 16 today i
also want to say thanks to
endes who just signed up via twitch and
his new member number 17. speaking of
endies we have a new
sponsor it is an underwear sponsor
and we were working today on how to
word the ad it's really funny
um listen to the the i'll mention this
i won't even actually mention the
company yet once they officially start
you'll know but here's one of the ways
that we figured out to word how these
underwear underwears
work the boxer briefs have multiple
ergonomic compartments to prevent
skin on skin contact preventing
chafing now that the weather is warming
up that's a line
from an ad from a new uh
a new advertiser we have so that's going
to be interesting
and i may even address the age-old
question of
boxers versus briefs in this
compartmental
underwear segment every black market gun
was bought as a legal firearm
somewhere somewhere right yeah it could
have been in a different country but
that's absolutely true aaron
that's absolutely true the black market
for guns is fueled by less regulation
easier for someone to quickly get them
and resell or smuggle them to canada too
no
obviously 100 100
i want to say thanks to liam gentry liam
just signed up at joinpakman.com taking
advantage
of the immoral but not a legal coupon
code immoral21
thanks liam very much appreciate your
support also
candiespoppin just subscribed via twitch
with the message so nice to get reliable
info from a good source love your
channel and watch you all the time
thanks candies
appreciate that if you're just joining
us you've missed nothing we are standing
by for joe biden's announcement on
gun control executive
orders he is doing it he is doing it
and i think that it is a great idea bae
photo says
so joe manchin yeah i wasn't
joking or exaggerating when uh joe biden
won and i said a lot of things now
depend on joe manchin and a lot of
people wrote to me and they said
sir there's no way joe manchin has that
much power
look at what's going on right now
mike says do gun rights people who cry
about the right to bear arms realize
that the second amendment was written
when it took 10 minutes to load a gun
and could only shoot one musket ball at
a time
some of them do some of them don't
some of them do some of them don't don't
i want to say thank you to
montian for gifting can you
imagine 20 subscriptions
on twitch 20 subs gifted by
montyan very exciting that's a massive
dump of gifts
incredible what's the most subs anyone
has gifted in one shot
i think 50. so historically
the biggest gifter is i'm inconsolable
with 542 gifts
david chadman is in second place with
323
and spudnik is in third place with 258
and then there's a bunch of people right
around 100 but the most
the biggest uh sub dump at once
was i believe 50. 50.
will i be modeling the new underwear we
have not yet decided on that
we have not yet decided whether i will
be modeling the underwear for our new
sponsor that's something to look at at
some point in the future
not a decision has not yet been reached
but we'll see we'll see i don't know if
that's something people would want me to
do
okay a few other clips i wanted to look
at here
um hold on where was it
nope no hold on there was another clip i
wanted to play from fox news maybe it's
further down
lloyd no this isn't it
huh where was there was another clip i
wanted to go over with you guys
wasn't biden
no not this
oh by the way eric trump was on the gut
felt show
this was the only actual funny segment
on the entire show but it wasn't it was
funny despite itself it wasn't trying to
be funny
that was like the other night um
the crowd responses are painful let's
see i'm just curious
who doesn't have an id and if the person
doesn't have an id
don't you think voting isn't really a
primary concern
given that it's impossible to rent an
apartment get a bank account
or sign up for my new newsletter on the
benefits of gold and silver
you know now it's never been a better
time
really weird show it's it's a very very
strange show
i want to say thank you to william
morrow
william morrow just signed up at
jointpakman.com
and his new member number 40.
thank you so much william very much
appreciate that also a big shout out to
tony mcdonald
tony mcdonald is new member number 41.
oh speaking of which
so i i've been continuing to try to do
the telemarketer scam calls where i call
telemarketers back and people have been
sending me messages saying like hey i
got a voicemail from this number saying
you know urgently call them before i get
arrested by the time i call the numbers
are typically disconnected but i was
thinking that in the next call when i'm
asked for my name
i would you do a combination of common
last names like i would say my last name
is like mcdonald robertson smith and
and spell it really slowly that's the
like that's the only thing i can
i'm not kid boga guys i'm not kit boga i
understand
but i'm going to keep trying to do
others i'm going to keep trying to do
more of those calls
um when the biden's secret police starts
coming for real americans i will hide
them in the sewers on top of the
confiscated bibles and ar-15s exactly
fool in the reins is out of curiosity
would you support repealing the second
amendment
so i i wouldn't because i don't think
it's necessary to do that to properly
regulate guns and it would be insanely
difficult
okay ryan says i support the equality
act except the part on school sports i
haven't heard many democrats speak on
that part are they scared to disagree
publicly
it's possible i've addressed that a lot
i've addressed that a lot on this
program
we just had the biggest ever single dump
of memberships
odwd inc has just dumped
51 memberships that sets the new record
on twitch for a one-time membership dump
51 memberships what's 51 plus 41 that's
gotta be like a thousand right
i don't know it seems like a really high
number um
very much appreciate that odw
and we'll we'll get an update as to
where that puts odw
in the grand scheme of things that's a
big number though
that is a hell of a number that now puts
odw
solidly in fourth place for lifetime
gifts on twitch at 160.
wow 160. yeah so top
lifetime gift is still inconsolable with
542
top one time gift is odw with 51.
it's based af yeah my word my my
thoughts exactly
uh also i'm not ignoring anybody guys
thanks to last throw
and mugen for signing up numbers 93 and
94.
and also thank you for clinton hopkins
for signing up on my website remember we
love twitch subs
but twitch takes a cut we keep 98
for website subs and uh that's number
95.
you have not missed anything i see
people coming in asking have i missed it
have i missed it no we are standing by
for joe biden
imminently set to announce executive
action
on guns guns guns guns expecting to do
something about so-called ghost
guns now if you were trump you would
think a ghost gun is a
gun that's physically invisible just
like he thought you know when
when a fighter jet is invisible to radar
trump thought it was literally invisible
to the naked eye
biden expected to do something about
ghost guns
and then i don't know what else i don't
know what else we're standing by
okay pc says wait if you have a thousand
dollars why would you spend it on a gun
instead keep saving you dumb when will
pfizer come to india with its vaccine
bad situation here
i don't know the answer to that but um
india is starting to manufacture
vaccines
which is a good thing how can you say
equality but then respond with
except for that's a deep
philosophical uh oh people are asking i
don't address
whether i'm a gun owner on the show
i've decided it's just not something
that i'm going to address one way or the
other
it is what it is i am what i am svelt
duck says i hope you're planning to do a
segment on the embarrassing stimulus
takes
dan crenshaw recently presented on jre
yes i actually recorded a segment on
that today
um i we do a deep dive it's like a
20-minute segment
on yesterday dan crenshaw took joe rogan
for a ride yesterday
it was stunning i might even have a
little bit of the clip
uh i don't no i don't
yeah that's on today's show but and
speaking of which if you want to see my
full breakdown of the
hysterical dan crenshaw joe rogan
interview it'll be live very soon
for our website members others will have
to wait until later tonight
yeah dan cringeshaw exactly right
exactly right nra is about to get some
badly needed donations and membership
fee and gun stores about to be rolling
in cash
that's true you know there's nothing
better for gun sales
than a democratic president trying to do
things about gun safety
it is the best thing for gun sales and
we know this
we know this uh if you look at obama gun
sales up
even though he didn't really even get
anything done trump in gun sales down
because they're not fear-mongering about
the president's going to take all your
guns
people asking why i'm not a twitch
partner yet and you get a bigger slice
of the subpai i don't think you do
and i'm not a twitch partner because if
you're a twitch partner you're not
allowed to stream anywhere else
we have a really strong presence on the
youtube
a 1.3 million
subscribers so i don't want to i don't
want to stop streaming on youtube
israel mckenzie says when the first
amendment was written you could own a
private army and private warships
so the whole week muskets this is
questionable
that is not untrue really fox for a
network that doesn't care about black
people you have no issue
using us for your poor news comedy
please do a deep dive
zaran says david you have one of the
best shows i watched do you think hr one
will pass the senate said
sadly i don't sadly i don't i wish i did
aaron says i'm getting the jnj vaccine
tomorrow does it make a difference which
vaccine to take
no um i got moderna two doses i know a
lot of people
say whoa whoa jnj is less efficacious
jnj was tested later when uh variants
were more widespread
more than likely the moderna and pfizer
are are similarly efficacious against
the variants
any vaccine you can get is nearly 100
effective at preventing hospitalization
and at preventing death so get any
vaccine you can get also jnj
logistically is simpler
because it is just uh just one dose
just one dose i want to say thank you to
jeff
arbuckle jeff just went to join
pacman.com and signed up using the
unpublished coupon code
immoral21 i also want to say thank you
to five
port studios for the twitch sub and
theorex for the twitch sub putting us at
98
new subs today um
am i seeing diminished youtube growth
yeah everybody is
news and politics is just growing more
slowly right now
so whereas i think in december we added
like 55 000
subs um we only added about 12 000 last
month let's listen to kamala harris my
own two eyes
what a bullet can do to the human body
i've held hands with the hands of
parents
who have lost a child i have
seen let's maybe go let's go over here
yeah this will be better for us
from the top
[Applause]
good morning
over the course of my career i have seen
gun violence up close i've looked at
autopsy photographs
i've seen with my own two eyes what a
bullet can do
to the human body right i've held hands
with the hands of parents who have lost
a child
i have seen children who were
traumatized
by the loss of a parent or sibling
and i have fought my entire career to
end this violence
and to pass reasonable gun safety laws
time and again as progress has stalled
we've all asked what are we waiting for
because we aren't waiting for a tragedy
i know that
we've had more tragedy than we can bear
we aren't waiting for solutions either
because the solutions
exist they already exist
people on both sides of the aisle
want action real people
on both sides of the aisle want action
so all that is left is the will
and the courage to act
time to do something but what will they
do
and president joe biden has the will
and the courage to act
[Applause]
as a united states senator joe biden
took on the gun lobby not once but twice
and he won in 1993
he worked to pass the brady handgun
violation prevention act this law
established a background check system
and has kept
more than three million firearms
out of the hands of dangerous people
a year later he worked to pass another
law
to ban assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines
for 10 years and as vice president
joe biden led the obama biden
administration's efforts
to reduce gun violence in fact we were
just reminiscing that he and i talked
back then
about his work because i was attorney
general at the time of california
right and his work resulted in nearly
two dozen actions from narrowing the gun
show loophole
to expanding funding from mental health
services
and as you will hear in a moment
president joe biden
is a leader with great will
great determination and even greater
empathy he has seen the grief
of all of those who have lost a loved
one to gun violence
it is for them for all of us
that he will never ever give up
on this fight and it is now my great
honor
to introduce the president of the united
states joe biden
all right what will he announce let's
listen carefully here
[Applause]
quick uh standardization and removal of
a little step stool that kamala was
using and we will hear from joe biden
thank you kamala madam vice president
thank you very much
you know we're joined today by the
attorney general
merrick garland who i've asked to
prioritize
gun violence it's also good to see the
second gentleman
who is here and uh it's good to see the
first lady dr
jill biden who cares deeply about this
issue
not a medical doctor fox news will
remind you darren i see so many members
of congress who've led in this fight
so many of you who've never given up so
many of you are
in can absolutely determined as murphen
and brothers are
to get this done we've got a long way to
go which seems like we always have a
long way to go
but also today we're taking steps to
confront not just the gun crisis
but what is actually a public health
crisis
nothing nothing i'm about to recommend
in any way impinges on the second
amendment right
they're phony arguments suggesting that
these are second amendment rights at
stake for what we're talking about don't
fall for it
but no amendment no amendment to the
constitution is absolute
you can't yell crowd you can't yell fire
in a crowded movie theater
called the freedom of speech from the
very beginning you couldn't own any
weapon you wanted to own
from the very beginning of the second
amendment existed certain people weren't
allowed to have weapons
so the idea is just bizarre to suggest
that some of the things were recommended
are contrary to the constitution it's
malarkey gun violence
in this country is an epidemic let me
say it again
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic
and it's an international embarrassment
you know we saw it again last night as i
was
coming to the oval office i got the
word that in south carolina a
physician with his wife
two grandchildren and a person working
at his house
was gunned down all five
so many people so many people sitting
here today
know that well unfortunately
you know they know what it's like
when the seconds change your life
forever
i've had the
pleasure of getting to meet an awful
circumstances
many of you many of you who've lost
your children your husbands your wives
you know they know what it's like to
bury a piece of their soul deep in the
earth
we understand that mark and uh
and jackie i want to tell you
it's always good to see you but not
under these circumstances i want to say
before i introduce the rest of the folks
is you know what a lot of people have
not been through
what they've been through don't
understand it takes a lot of courage
to come to an event like this they're
absolutely
absolutely determined to make change
but mark and jackie whose son daniel was
a first grader in san diego elementary
school
daniel loves sports loves outdoor sports
getting muddy i see my friend fred
gutenberg
his daughter jamie was a freshman at
marjory stoneman douglas high school she
was an accomplished dancer
i see brandon wolfe over the shooting at
the
at the at the impulse at the pulse club
nightclub
he survived but his two best friends
died greg jackson who was just
walking down the street when he was
caught crossfire of a gunfight
and of course i see a close friend of
jill's and mine
congresswoman gabby gifford who was here
who was who was speaking with her
constituents in front of a grocery store
in her state when she was shot and a
member of her staff was killed
you know they're here
and their pain is immense and you know
what a lot of you hopefully many of you
don't know
is you've gone through a trauma no
matter how much you work to make sure
others don't go through it
every time you show up an event like
this it brings back
when you got that phone call it brings
back the immediacy
of what happened at that moment so i
genuinely mean it
thank you thank you for having the
courage the courage to be here
the courage to continue this fight
senator blumenthal understands it a lot
of the folks out here understand it
but it takes real courage so thank you
to turn pain into purpose and demand
that we
take the action that gives meaning to
the word
enough enough enough
enough because what they want you to
know
what they want you to do is not just
listen
every day in this country 316 people
are shot every single day 106 of them
die every day
our flag was still flying at half staff
for the victims of the horrific murder
of eight
primarily asian-american people in
georgia
when 10 more lives were taken in a mass
murder in colorado
you probably didn't hear but between
those two incidents
less than one week apart there were more
than 850 additional shootings
850 that took the lives of more than 250
people and left
500 500 injured
this is an epidemic for god's sake and
it has to stop
so i'm here to talk about two things
tell us what you're doing
the steps we're going to take
immediately right and second
the accident needs to be taken going
forward to curb the epidemic of gun
violence
i asked the attorney general and his
team
to identify for me immediate concrete
actions i could take now
without having to go through the
congress and today i'm announcing
several initial steps my administration
is taking here we go
curb this epidemic of gun violence much
more need be done but the first
first want to rein in the proliferation
of so-called ghost
guns these are guns that are homemade
built from a kit that include directions
on how to finish the firearm you can go
buy the kit they have no serial numbers
so when they show up at a crime scene
they can't be traced
spooky and the buyers aren't required to
pass a background check to buy the kit
to make the gun consequently anyone
anyone from a criminal to a terrorist
can buy this kit as little as 30 minutes
put together
a weapon you know i want to see these
kits treated as
firearms right under the gun control act
which is going to require that the
seller and manufacturers
make the key parts with serial numbers
and run background checks on the buyers
when they walk in to buy
that package the section action we're
going to the second action we're going
to take
back in 2000 year 2000 the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms
released a report on its investigations
of firearms trafficking in america
the report was a pivotal value it was an
important tool
for policymakers when i was in the
senate and beyond at all levels
to stop firearms from being illegally
diverted into dangerous hands
today with online sales and
ghost guns times and trafficking methods
have changed
and we have to adjust we also have to
ask the justice department to release a
new annual report
this report will better help
policymakers address
firearms trafficking as it is today
not what it was yesterday a third change
we want to treat pistols modified with
stabilizing braces
with the seriousness they deserve a
stabilizing brace hook and a pencil
essentially
makes that pistol a hell of a lot more
accurate and a mini rifle
as a result it's more lethal effectively
turning into a short-barreled rifle
that's what the alleged shooter in
boulder appears to have done
i want to be clear that these
modifications to firearms that make them
more lethal
should be subject to the national
firearms act
the national firearms act requires that
a potential owner pay 200
fee and submit their name and other
identify information to the justice
department
just as they would if they went out and
purchased a silencer
for a gun fourthly
during my campaign for president i
wanted to make it easier for states to
adopt
extreme risk protection order laws or
family member
to petition a court in their
jurisdiction
congressman sicilian mate david chipman
for anyone purchasing a gun at a
and one thing an order preventing
the abuser from coming in these are some
of the best tools we have right now to
prevent gun violence and save lives
but all these bills they had supported
both democrats and republicans in the
house
and universal background checks are
supported by the vast majority of the
american people
and i might add the vast majority of
responsible gun owners
so let me be clear this is not a
partisan issue
among the american people right this is
a view
by the american people as an american
issue
and i'm willing to work with anyone to
get these done
and it's long past time that we act
now i know this has been a hobby horse
of mine for a long time
got it done once we should also ban
assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines in this country
so that 10 years we had it done
the number of mass shootings actually
went down
even law enforcement officials have told
me and told other
champions of this legislation they
sometimes
remember guys he's announcing things
he's doing
things he would like the senate to pass
that the house passed
and then just things he wants done we're
going to break it down after 100
bullets that can be fired
from that weapon nobody needs that
nobody needs that
we got that done when i was a united
states senator it wasn't easy
going up against the gun lobby but it
saved lives
and we should also eliminate gun
manufacturers from the immunity they
received from the congress
you realize youtube's back by the way
and the people here because they're so
knowledgeable
on there and the rose garden
but what piece of people don't realize
the only industry in america a billion
dollar industry
that can't be sued as exempt from being
sued
or gun manufacturers imagine how
different it would be
had that same exemption been available
to tobacco companies
who knew who knew and lied about the
danger
they were causing the cancer caused and
the like
imagine where we'd be but this is the
only outfit
that is exempt from being sued
if i get one thing on my list the lord
came down and said joe you get one of
these
give me that one because i tell you what
wow there would be a come to the lord
moment these folks would have real
quickly
but they're not they're not they're
exempt
i know that the conversation about guns
in this country can be a difficult one
but even here there's much more common
ground
than we anyone would believe there's
much more common ground
everything that's being proposed today
is totally consistent with the second
amendment
and there's a wide consensus behind the
need to take action
i know that when overwhelming majorities
americans want to see something change
that would affect their lives
and it still doesn't change it can be
demoralizing to our fellow citizens
it can feel like our entire political
process is broken
i know it's painful and frustrating that
we haven't made the progress
that we'd hoped for but it took five
years to get bradyville passed and it
took even more years to work to pass the
assault weapons ban
and it saved lives no matter how long it
takes
we're going to get these passed we're
not going to give up
we have an opportunity to fulfill the
first responsibility of government
to keep our people safe and in the
process we can show the world and show
ourselves that democracy works
we can come together and get big things
done
when i look around and see such brave
survivors sitting out here in the rose
garden
public servants who devoted their lives
to dealing with this
advocates who feel strongly and are
pushing every day to make the rational
changes
and courageous parents and family
members
i know the progress even in this most
difficult of issues is possible
so folks this is just the start
we've got a lot of work to do but i know
almost every one of you sitting in the
garden here none of you ever given up
we're not going to give up now the idea
that we have so many people dying every
single day from gun violence in america
there's a blemish on our character as a
nation
let me say to all of you god bless you
but most importantly the memory
of all many of you have lost to the
senseless gun violence
and now i'd like to hand it over to the
attorney general
for him to speak and make some comments
so we're going to review all of this to
see somebody after this is over
thank you thank you thank you
thank you mr president and madam vice
president
we stand here today not at a moment of
tragedy
but in the midst of an enduring tragedy
so far this year guns have taken the
lives of an
estimated 11 000 of our neighbors
friends and fellow americans
[Music]
as the president explained
gun deaths in our country are occurring
at a staggering pace
on the order of about a hundred
americans killed every day
with hundreds more wounded i
am under no illusions about how hard it
is to solve the problem of gun violence
and i know that the department of
justice alone
cannot solve the problem it is a problem
that we must all work on together
in the collective effort to keep guns
out of the hands of criminals
and save lives but there is work for the
department to do
and we intend to do it today
the department of justice is announcing
several steps that we will take to keep
guns out of the hands of criminals and
reduce the risk of gun violence
first we will ensure that we understand
and measure the problem of criminal gun
trafficking
in a data driven way over
20 years ago atf undertook a gun
trafficking study
it then issued a report that provided
information
necessary to better understand and to
combat
criminal trafficking networks no
such study has been conducted since that
time
accordingly i have directed atf to begin
work on an updated study of criminal gun
trafficking one that will take into
account the fact that modern guns are
not simply cast or forged anymore
but can also be made of plastic printed
on a 3d printer
or sold in self-assembly kits
we will evaluate how some of our best
tools
including the national integrated
ballistics information network
and the national tracing center are
keeping up with the times
and we will analyze our criminal cases
and investigations to determine what
they can show us
about modern gun trafficking patterns
we expect that the lessons from this
study will help agents
prosecutors and policy makers tackle
modern criminal gun trafficking
enterprises
second we will close a regulatory
loophole that has contributed to the
proliferation
of so-called ghost guns federal law
requires that manufacturers mark
all firearms with serial numbers so they
can be traced if they are used in crimes
it also requires licensed firearms
dealers to run background checks
to ensure that individuals who are
barred it's crazy a lot of this stuff
isn't already being done
the emergence of ghost guns threatens
both
of these important law enforcement
objectives
currently individuals can buy kits that
contain
all or almost all of the parts they need
to assemble a gun
they can put a working weapon together
in as little as 30 minutes
the kits are aptly called buy
build shoot kits
yet because of a gap in the atf
regulations these kits may not be
considered firearms as a result
they are being made and sold without
serial numbers
and sold without background checks
within 30 days atf will issue a proposed
rule to plug that gap
and to enable law enforcement to trace
crime guns
and to keep guns from being sold to
those who cannot
lawfully possess them third
we will make clear that statutory
restrictions on short short-barreled
rifles apply
when certain stabilizing braces are
added to high-powered pistols
federal law requires the taxation and
registration of all
short-barreled rifles it does so because
these weapons are powerful yet easily
concealable
currently however some manufacturers
market and some
individuals purchase certain kinds of
stabilizing braces
that when attached to a pistol
effectively converted into a
short-barreled rifle
a weapon that is in the words of the
statute quote
intended to be fired from the shoulder
such braces make high-powered pistols
more stable and accurate
while still concealable within 60 days
atf will issue a proposed rule that will
make clear
that when a device marketed as a
stabilizing device
effectively turns a pistol into a
short-barreled rifle
it is subject to the requirements of the
statute
fourth we will publish model red
flag legislation for states
red flag laws as the president has
explained
allow family members or law enforcement
to petition for court orders
that temporarily bar people in crisis
from accessing
firearms if they present a danger to
themselves
or to others 19 states
and the district of columbia have
already made this important step
within 60 days the justice department
will publish model legislation
that will make it easier for states that
want to craft
laws permitting such emergency risk
orders
to do so fifth
we will empower our communities to
combat
and prevent gun violence
we all recognize that although law
enforcement plays an important role
gun violence is not a problem that law
enforcement alone
can solve
that's for sure
communities are an essential partner
an asset and a source of resources
and ideas those who are closest to the
problem
are a critical part of solving the
problem
to that end the justice department will
make available over one
billion dollars in funding through over
a dozen grant programs
that can be used to support
evidence-based intervention strategies
for reducing gun violence
such strategies include but are not
limited to street
outreach violence interrupters and
hospital-based violence intervention
services
i have directed all of our grant making
components
to come to make community violence
intervention
and preen prevention a priority
finally none of these measures or any of
the other
critical law enforcement work the
department does with respect to illegal
guns
can be effectively carried out without
strong leadership
that is why the president has nominated
david shipman to be the next
atf director
mr chipman has come up through the ranks
spending 25 years in the trenches
fighting illegal gun trafficking
and criminal enterprises his extensive
experience as an atf
agent will prove invaluable and i look
forward to working with him
looking out at many of you is not
only a reminder of the tragic toll
that gun violence takes on our
communities
but also of the resilience and
determination
that it will take to make our
communities safer
the department of justice shares your
commitment
and that of the president and of the
vice president
to stopping the plague of gun violence
and saving the lives of those we love
thank you
[Applause]
there goes biden into the crowd
salute gabby giffords
i wasn't supposed to do that i'd like to
see all of you thank you
thank you thank you let's get to work
all right so so really three categories
here
so the what's important to understand is
that
you know at the end biden says i would
love an assault weapons ban
that's not even on the list of things
passed by the house that he wants passed
by the senate so let's kind of go in
order so first of all
joe biden and merrick garland announcing
that they will be moving forward
uh unilaterally on
including ghost gun kits under
background check provisions
as firearms a new
annual report on guns treating pistols
that have been modified with stabilizing
braces
in the same way that rifles are treated
and making it easier for states to adopt
red flag laws where if someone for
example is found to be a danger to
themselves or others by a court
they would have their ability to own
firearms uh rest
limited during that period of time okay
those are the things
uh and oh and number five nominating an
atf director which has not had a
permanent director for some period of
time those are things joe biden is going
to do
then there are things joe biden is
asking
the senate to do so for example the
house has already passed the bill on
universal background checks
joe biden has asked the senate to pass
it so that then he can sign it
um the house has passed a bill
eliminating the charleston loophole
where if the fbi doesn't complete a
background check in three days you can
just get the gun
instead the modification would be if the
fbi doesn't
finish the background check in three
days then you just have to keep waiting
um and wants the
house and senate to pass that if someone
is under a stay away order a restraining
order or whatever the case may be
because of
domestic violence during that period of
time they are also not allowed to own
guns then joe biden so that's
he wants legislators to pass the third
category
is just things biden supports even
though there's
nothing going on which includes an
assault weapons ban and a ban on
high-capacity magazines and to end the
lawsuit exemption for gun manufacturers
so this is better than nothing the five
things that joe biden can do are good
things to do
the impact will be modest i mean it's
going to be modest it's
it's better than nothing but it's going
to be relatively modest impact
i don't know that the senate is going to
pass the stuff he wants the senate to
pass
and then the last two items items nine
and ten it's just sort of like
okay he wants it maybe someday there
will be legislation
but there isn't right now so if you're
on the
side that wants significantly more gun
safety regulations
you're not getting that much but you're
getting some important things
certainly more than we would have gotten
with a second uh term of donald trump
if you're on the side of you want
nothing done
at all and you believe that
this is an infringement on your rights
you're probably going to be furious and
you'll probably go out and try to buy
a whole bunch of guns so if you're
coming into this looking to be happy
or sad or upset or furious or whatever
you probably got something right like
you know when biden says i would like an
assault weapons ban
there's none in the works right now but
if you're you know a right-wing gun nut
just the fact that he wants it will make
you go completely crazy
it's not happening there's no
legislation it's a mixed bag
it's a mixed bag as people are saying uh
i know that the youtube stream went down
for a period of time and then came back
it wasn't on our end our primary stream
was working the entire time twitch
didn't go down facebook didn't go down
it was a youtube issue
eventually it came back okay so i
apologize for that even though it's not
my fault
um i do appreciate everybody joining me
we've got to get back to producing
today's show so it doesn't get delayed
thank you thank you thank you for
joining we'll be back with more streams
and things
very very soon